ever avoided dirty splashes from mud  puddles in the rainy season why to  prevent our clothes from getting stained  correct but when any other aqueous  solution does not leave colored stains  on our clothes why does this muddy  mixture leave some the muddy puddles are  examples of suspension solutions they  are heterogeneous mixtures in which  solute particles instead of getting  dissolved are suspended in the solvent  we can visually distinguish between  their components the size of the solute  particles is larger than 100 mm in  diameter and can lead to the tyndall  effect  tyndall effect means the scattering of a  beam of light by a medium containing  suspended particles in this case the mud  particles the large size of the mud  particles makes them visible through the  naked eye what can be done to separate  the solute particles from the solvent  please share your answers in the comment  section if you liked the video do share  it and subscribe to our youtube channel